when the old blood was found it must
have been thought a miracle
they called it the blood of the gods and
rightly so
for if you injected it into your veins
you would no longer be afflicted by the
weaknesses of the flesh
it follows that a city built upon this
blood would become mighty indeed
and so it was with the arnhem the supply
of the blood was controlled by the
healing church
and the church became the most powerful
of all
but the blood was foul infected
those who had taken the old blood began
transforming into hideous beasts
and eventually the church could keep the
scourge a secret no longer
fearing the populace itself they
retreated into cathedral ward
and devised a plan to fight back the
church hunters
were that plan the hunters in white
specialized in experimental blood
ministration
for the church continued to use the old
blood
albeit now with fear in their hearts the
hunters in black were a little different
their role was to violently purge this
town of the beastly scourge
beasthood was a cancer and with their
surgical white gloves
the black church hunters would rip the
beasthood from the hearts of the
animites
they were known to dispose of victims
even potential victims
before signs of sickness had even
manifested themselves
their black attire inspired fear in the
hearts of the animites
for if they decided that you had the
beast within you
then it was so but the beast lies
dormant within us
all and ironically the clerics
transformed into the most
terrifying beasts father is a title used
for clerics in a foreign land
and the healing church knew no such rank
an outsider
father gascoigne joined the ranks of the
black church hunters
perhaps he like many others was sick
and needed treatment perhaps he saw the
miracles that the church was performing
actual miracles that could have inspired
a new faith in the man
or perhaps it was the thirst for blood
that drew him here
for gascoigne turned out to be a truly
capable hunter
a fine addition to the ranks of the
church
gascoigne was partnered with another an
older hunter
by the name of henrique capable beyond
his years
this old man was easily recognizable in
his unique
yellow garb its description tells us
that they were a
fierce and gallant duo but also that
their partnership
led to henrique's tragically long life
he must have been very old indeed to be
tragically so
perhaps gascoin's access to the church
granted henrique
access to the old blood and it's
possible that the miraculous blood
granted him life beyond his years who
knows what that can do to a man
together henrik and gascoigne were a
part of the effort to purge yharnam of
the scourge
just two more hunters doing what hunters
must for the good of the city of course
gascoigne even found love outside the
church's walls within central ghana
a woman named viola blonde and favoring
a bright red brooch
perhaps the jewel was a gift from a
hunter
imagine being a man of yarnam during
this time
put yourself in this city as a
gudyanamite would you join the nightly
hunt with your brothers
fighting against the scourge you lock
your women and children
safely at home with incense at their
doors to ward away the beasts
you fight alongside the black church
hunters
though these men of the church are
watching you at all times
for any signs of the plague you fight
alongside those who would kill you
if they had to
in time viola fell pregnant soon after
gascoigne left the healing church
perhaps he had something more important
to him now
who are you i don't know your voice
but i know that smell are you a hunter
family must have pulled him away from
the church and on the night of our
unending hunt
we find this young girl alone in her
family's home
[Music]
daddy never came back from the hunt and
she went to find him
but now she's gone too i'm all alone
and scared we're looking for a woman
with a red brooch
and a man garbed in black
[Music]
imagine being gascoigne at this point in
the story
an ex-hunter of the healing church he
still wears the tattered black garb that
shows how faithfully he served the
church
in their hunt and tonight the hunt
is worse than any night before it
tonight
the line between man and beast is
blurred
the beast men of janam cry for death to
their ministers
if they see you wearing the minister's
garb
this is the exact same thing gascoin was
wearing
it's unclear exactly what happened in
the tomb of urden
but here we find father gascoigne
surrounded by the corpses of fellow
yanamites
hacking them to pieces completely lost
to his thirst for blood
on a rooftop nearby we find his wife
dead my mom wears a
red chilled brooch it's so big and
beautiful you won't miss it oh i mustn't
forget
if you find my mum you've had this music
box
it plays one of daddy's favorite songs
and when daddy forgets us
we play it for him so he remembers i'm
so silly running off without it
the small music box received from a
young yanum girl
plays a song shared by her mother and
father
inside the lid is a small scrap of paper
perhaps an old message
two names can be made out however
faintly
viola and gus coin when we play their
song
the husband recoils in agony ghostcoin
is losing himself to the beastly scourge
he wants to forget but the music reminds
him of his wife
his children his city his humanity
his dead wife his broken city his
despair
his wife is likely dead at his hand for
she didn't have their music box to
remind him of who he was as she had done
many times before gescoine is beyond
saving
and you end his suffering it almost
sounds as if his last words are
forgive me
we don't have the heart to give a child
her dead mother's brooch
instead we send her to urden chapel she
can't stay in this house alone
for neither her mother nor her father is
coming back for her
better to send her to a safe place hello
miss hunter still can't find my mom
oh okay i can wait but
isn't there something i can do maybe mom
and dad are stuck
out there waiting for me to come and
find them
what do you think miss hunter we sent
her to urden chapel
yes okay don't you miss hunter i love
you almost as much as mom and dad
and grandad she never appears there
trace the path she would have taken
imagine this little girl
creeping through a sewer filled with
crawling corpses and carrion crows
to run past it all and come so close to
the chapel
only to spy this thing at the end of the
tunnel
it eats the little girl and after your
revenge
you find the bloodied white ribbon upon
its remains
ah you haven't by any chance
see my little sister have you someone
did come back for the little girl
turns out gascoigne had two daughters
and you just sent one to her death
i told you to look after the house but
she's run off somewhere
she's still quite small and wears this
big white ribbon
have you seen her out there anywhere
[Music]
oh how did this happen
why would she ever go outside
at least i'll absolutely jump
remember her bye
[Music]
the truly sad thing is a friend of the
family was waiting at urden tomb around
this time
the one the littlest daughter calls
grandat
he could have met the youngest daughter
there had the pig
not consumed her in the tunnel instead
henrique goes mad here in this place
perhaps he discovered that someone
killed his friend
or perhaps since the littlest daughter
calls him grandad
he discovered the corpse of his daughter
viola
[Music]
perfect timing i must warn you
not to go near the tomb below urden
chapel in the cathedral ward
henrik an old hunter
has gone mad and he's
my mark
[Music]
when we arrive we're already too late
as with gascoigne loss pushes henrique
over the edge
we've seen that hunters turn into
terrible beasts so the hunter must
become the hunted
that wasn't necessary of you but you
have my thanks we made it with our lives
you're not bad at all
you must have killed gascon as well then
he was falling apart i'm sure it had to
be done
but try to keep your hands clean
a hunter should hunt beasts
leave the hunting of hunters to me
gascoigne killed his wife we killed
gascoigne
henrique tried to kill us so eileen
killed henrique
the last surviving daughter throws
herself off a ledge
upon receiving her sister's bloodied
ribbon and the bloodline of gascoin
ends here however
somewhere in another hunt perhaps you
never spoke
to the littlest daughter she never went
looking for her parents
she never traveled down this tunnel
she stayed home until her sister
returned and they huddled together
until morning came i won't be afraid
i know i do the morning always comes
you